American prisons are one of the few
places in our culture rain disputable
employed prisons that I've been in
poetry is quite important it's an art
that you don't need a lot of equipment
to do if you memorize a poem you need
any equipment at all to recite it and
you can write in your head one of those
guys at Guantanamo put this in the palm
in my new book incised his palms into
styrofoam cups until he got writing
material mountains Tom said to written
them into soap and eventually they're
memorized I mean the poetry the very
things that make it small and it also
make it unit and make it very essential
the fact you don't need a lot of
equipment the fact that I can be
reciting to a poem by myself while I'm
in solitary or well I'm driving or
taking a shower can't do that with your
electronic instrument I don't think is
that you have ones you can use in the
shower but you get what I mean and as
far as I could see which is not so far
in the pond reading translations and
their translations done basically by
legal interpreters they're not
translations that are literary as far as
I could see as in prison there's a range
of sophistication mean I did some
teaching in a medium-security prison
which had some lifers in it those guys
wrote my graduate student similar
something I published they're lifers a
lot of time to read a lot of time to
think that a lot of time to practice an
art they're not going anywhere and they
become sophisticated writers that's
moving in a way most moving to pay were
the opposite really young kids very
naive writers
Oh mom I know I did something wrong I
wish I could make you a better song you
know very crudely Braund Ernest
sometimes he could tell that they had
not done so well in high school and
they're innocent there's a very nasty
thing something or someone nasty things
longer had to do with drugs and that was
one of the things that struck you about
prison where I was anyway was this
terrific range and the centrality of the
art those prisons were interesting play
eventually I couldn't stand it I some
people get into it they do it forever it
sounds like a joke and reminded me too
much of junior high school I couldn't
stand the regimentation every time I had
to put a coin in a locker with my watch
and take it out which book I could have
and couldn't and when I but pentas he
did something wrong every time and it
was just like junior high school also
did something wrong every time so I it
just was too depressing for me to really
become one of the main people doing this
it's one of the few those poetry
readings that I think they've migrated
to another institution at that time it
was Massachusetts institution in North
Walk same person Malcolm X wasn't it's
as though those people it was racially
much less segregated than your average
Ivy League dining hall as if those guys
had gone through American racial
nuttiness and come out on the other side
somehow so that you go to some see the
stupid scene at Princeton or somewhere
and people were segregated by race and
here these guys the poetry reading
they're not doing that in prison is
Rapunzel
some of the murderers bank robbers
certainly drug dealers
you